ron we discussed uh the the the book yes
and there's another uh let me off at the
top yeah let me off the top this is
another you were the first celebrity
ever to appear on the cover of dog dog
fancy magazine
and this is a great honor
yeah that's you and your dog baxter
beloved baxter yeah and um you care a
lot about animals i do um
my dog is they say that man's best
friend is his dog and literally my best
friend is baxter um he's my only friend
yeah
he said that your dog is your only
friend
yep oh
i'm sorry he's a great pal
told myself i wouldn't cry
wow out of a [ __ ] okay i'm sorry
i didn't caught me i didn't mean it my
friend i asked you about your dog i
didn't you're a real kid sometimes
anyway uh yes i love my dog you love
your dog
and um and you love uh you have i love
animals i always have in fact i
mentioned in the book uh my love for
animals i in fact i created my own chart
i want to ask you about yes you have a
animal hierarchy chart of intelligence
yes of intelligence of the greatest
animals in the kingdom okay and uh i
want you to walk us through this because
it's a fact it's scientifically proven
okay this is called your chart of
human positionology positionality and
and why don't you walk us through this
we'll start at the top who's at the top
here the socratic eagle okay all right
um you love the eagles there's nothing
more majestic than the bald eagle okay
uh of course the second most intelligent
animal is the rooster okay uh rooster
doesn't get a lot of credit okay um
and then of course it's almost redundant
hermit crab and salmon okay i don't
follow at all why the hermit crab then
there's the cheetah okay
here's what's interesting you put
mankind down here
with the narwhal the dog and the cat
well believe me these these are you know
superior creatures up here there's no
doubt okay
and then and then at the bottom oh now
you got the donkey the parrot and then
you have the lowly sea otter
the dumbest animal on the planet earth
yes and baxter's even told me he's had
conversations with sea otters and he
said they're just boring as hell
they just go on and on about how much
fish they've caught okay i can swim on
my back and crack open a clam with some
rocks and you're like okay
i know that
wow okay this is and you said this is
all fact oh fact in fact i love the bald
eagles so much in fact i i i illegally
got an american bald eagle once from a
russian and
uh incredible kept it in my house
for eight days um how'd that go uh well
the first day first couple days he just
fought and clawed me and scratched me
flew around very chaotically in my house
by the third day he'd calmed down a
little bit um the fourth day i was able
to put an uncle sam hat on him and
he was willing to ride a little tiny
circus tricycle around really i think
he's wonderful do you think he was
happening he was starting to really love
living with me and on the eighth day i'm
like let's go outside and we i opened
the door and just flew away
and i couldn't track him and but he's
just so smart yeah so smart